This video is brought to you by surf shark, VPN.
[Inaudible].
Greg here,
ready to have a most resplendent time talking about a film with the best
dialogue in the history of cinema.
Billy, the kid he's famous, dude.
That's bad.
Bill and Ted's excellent.
Adventure is frequently dismissed as a silly teen flag about two stone arrests
metal heads, who would literally rather do anything than go to school.
But what if it's secretly a genius film about the radical power of learning?
No way, no way.
Well, maybe way dude, maybe way, dude.
Let's find out as bill and Ted's excellent. Adventure is deep are dumb.
We swear we'll be.
No.
Or maybe the opposite anyway,
spoilers and a most triumphant time ahead. But before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to this week. Sponsor surf sharp VPN.
A VPN is a virtual private network that encrypts your web traffic.
So you can protect your passwords, photos and private messages.
Online surf shark is simple and easy to use and it doesn't slow down your
internet speed. Unlike some other VPs, you can also use it on any device.
So you're protected no matter where you go surf shark, isn't just a VPN.
It also offers additional features like clean web, which blocks ads,
and now where the may pop up while browse.
There are other feature why search protects your browser from serving you
targeted ads or sponsored sites.
If you use the link in the description right now,
you can get surf shark VPN for 85% off its normal price.
Plus three extra months for free go to surf
shark.deal/wise, crack or click the link in the description,
protect yourself online and download surf shark VPN today.
Now back to the show.
Now a quick recap bill and Ted centers on two pleasant metal heads were
remarkable only in the fact that they are the future saviors of the world.
Except right now they're about to flunk history,
which will get young Kiana Reed sent to military school.
Failed history. You flunk out of school. You know what that would mean?
Don't you tit that I would have to go to oats, military Academy.
And destroy the dual SIG ban.
Their only means of salvation give a killer oral report on an apparently random
assortment of historical time periods.
Just when all hope seems lost and Kiano might have to open a bug.
A guy named Rufus from the future shows up with a dope time traveling phone
booth. They use it,
the kidnap historical figures bring them to the present and AC out of that
presentation as resolved our dudes on track to save the world so long
as they can learn to play instruments. First, the end. So good. This time,
traveling stone affair possibly be deeper than the sofa eyes of one.
Mr. Reeves, we got two arguments to throw at you. Here's number one,
bill and Ted might be all about the failures of Western style education.
It's no secret that these dudes do not care about their own learning.
Oh, we're late for what.
The classroom is presented as a place where facts are to be memorized and
regurgitated. Not only is this a very boring way to learn.
It's also a really big societal problem.
According to the educator and philosopher,
Paolo Ferreri and his banking concept of education.
Crary argued that the Western education functions under the premise that the
teacher knows everything important and the student functionally knows nothing
as education is there for something to be given from the teacher to the student,
the positive like coins until your dumb old piggy bank of a brain.
According to [inaudible],
the result is that the scope of action allowed to the students extends only as
far as receiving, filing and storing the deposits.
This is visible right away and bill and Ted's. Well,
we see the chalkboard of a social studies classroom filled with a short list of
historical time periods waiting to be systematically deposited into these
impressionable minds bill and Ted's teacher.
Doesn't ask them to argue about the possible causes of world war one or
theorizing powder winds were good for ed baggy.
He asked him to recite admittedly, very simple facts.
With Joan of arc Noah's wife.
Rory who spent his life educating impoverished disenfranchised folks in Brazil
believed the banking model to be inherently oppressive.
Treating students like adaptable, manageable beings.
You feel someone's brain with random facts and make sure that they don't have
the will or ability to think critically about those facts. And from there,
you don't have to worry about anyone changing the world,
whether through a mass protest movement or weirdly influential metal
bed. And this is a problem with normal school.
It certainly dialed up to 11 and military school,
an institution built to teach kids that shout out and listen to authority and
federally.
It's the prospect of Ted leaving wild stallions to become a cadet mindlessly
doing burpees that threatens the very rad utopia that all boy Rufus was
sent to protect.
But how do you overcome the drone minded nature of education banking according
to [inaudible] you do so by becoming an add to participant in your learning
specifically,
Fraley believed in the power of problem posing education in which the teacher
enters a dialogue with the students, rendering all participants,
jointly responsible for a process in which all grow Kyla,
like a teacher who encourages you to argue with them about George Washington's
farewell address instead of quizzing you about what year he crossed the
Delaware.
And problem posing seems at least a bit similar to what's happening between
Rufus and bill and Ted.
They're not too dumdums for him to fill with information.
He approaches them with reverence and respect. Although, admittedly,
my guy is in a real weird spot because he both has to help them and
worship them as savings of the world.
Rufus shows them the time machine teaches them how to use it.
That book will give you the number of any place you want.
To go and explains this implications.
These are the circuits of history. Gentlemen even.
Gives a little historical background, Australia.
1805, the friendship just invaded, but.
Then he leaves them to their own devices. Gentlemen.
On your own.
Bill and Ted now must pursue a more active educational model,
essentially rounding up a crew of historical figures to become their substitute
teachers along the way they creatively solve various issues.
They encounter ranging from broken antennas to figuring out how to get in touch
with the medieval begs of their dreams.
How are we going to meet him key to the problem?
Posing educational style for every said is communication.
As he put it authentic thinking,
thinking that is concerned about reality does not take place in ivory tower
isolation, but only in communication by communication.
We can only hope that Freddie was imagining this glorious exchange.
Our boys have over Socrates writing just before me.
The only true wisdom, consistent knowing that you know nothing.
That's us.
Dude.
What's more bill and Ted immediately enter a dialogue with Socrates
aura show crates,
sharing their own wisdom gleaned from growing up in the eighties.
All we are is dust in the wind.
Dude just
went, dude.
Which appropriately blows this Athenians mind over the course of their journey
instead of simply memorizing Joan of arc name,
they'll learn about her youthful achievements instead of memorizing Sigmund
Freud's theory of adipocyte complex Ted undergoes analysis by the good
doctor, perhaps most importantly,
bill and Ted are empowered with the knowledge that they have a tremendous effect
over the history. They all our saviors,
after all this notion of a student's active role in the making of history,
couldn't possibly be more antithetical to the feeling you get when memorizing
facts about Alexander, the great as fairy puddle problem, posing education,
train students in the art of how to see the world, not as a static reality,
but as a reality and process and transformation while [inaudible] was talking
about empowering people to think they can change the present are their own
circumstances.
This film little in lies is that I did by making bill and Ted actually
of change in the future.
As they learn how to control the forces around them and harness that power to
help them achieve their goals.
And you can almost see what ferry calls the emergence of consciousness and
critical intervention. In reality.
The report will time travel back to two days ago,
steal your dad's keys and leave.
In a weird or perhaps slightly metaphorical way.
Bill and Ted are taking charge of their own education and along the way,
discovering their own agency and even learning something.
Is sometimes known as the father of modern diet.
He was the teacher of Plato who was in turn,
the teacher of Aristotle and like Ozzy Osborne,
which repeatedly accused of corruption of the yacht.
Now, when I first heard this idea, I thought, Oh, hell no, come on.
This movie is dumb as hell.
And maybe it's a stretch to compare stoner bros.
The kids rising up against the government in South America. But I got to say,
I'm pretty convinced on this one.
So convinced I'm going to rate this argument pretty deep,
but now we've got to get to the real wild stuff. Argument. Number two,
here's the pitch,
not only is this movie about the failures of our education system,
but it's also an exploration of the shortcomings of the written word itself.
it all right. To get to the bottom of this,
we need to look at the dichotomy between an all versus a literary society.
I E one dominated by what comes out of your mouth hole or is received by our
ear holes versus one dominated by what you read via your aisles
and right bill and Ted begins in the modern world where the written word
reign Supreme, we all met around society through and through,
but they are punished for their refusal to, you know,
read and learn fixed facts about history correctly,
thus leading them to eminent academic failure. However,
bill and Ted are the absolute embodiment of a burgeoning oral culture giving
their tendency to communicate via song and music.
Even when this score with futuristic weirdos, according to scholar,
landline quiz,
the way history functions in an oral versus literary society is critical to
understanding bill and Ted in a literary society.
Lonquist explains historical narratives are fixed, rigid and unchangeable.
After all,
you can't change the printed word in a normal society where storytellers can
adapt each story,
a song to suit their audiences left reign Supreme.
Like how home is Odyssey is likely a combination of several different enduring
stories told from generation to generation in ancient Greece that eventually
got written down.
What's more liberal societies tend to be more equal because it's LUN
Quintz explains.
The written word was historically weaponized by the powerful to deny rights,
the illiterate masses and contrast oral traditions like folk
songs or folklore are accessible to just about everyone.
Maybe it's a weird coincidence,
but just about every literary society we visit in Billington is violent and
cruel. While all based societies like Athens are presented as peaceful.
It was most tranquil. And also.
They kidnapped Socrates who was one of the last philosophers of ancient Greece
that we know of to communicate solely through oral tradition.
He also famously feared that reading and writing would cause the downfall of
civilization.
The only reason we think we know what kind of stuff Socrates said is because his
student Plato wrote a bunch of it down and keep them with this bill.
And Ted seemed to epitomize the egalitarian nature of an oral society.
When cramming for their tests,
they solicit the conversational anecdotal help of various patrons
of the circle, K and keeping with classic oral.
The lady in that car over there said that Marco polo was in the year 1275.
And critically their teacher perhaps sensing their resistance to literary
culture,
throws our boys a bone and offers them the chance to pass via
adult presentation.
Prairie might extra appreciate the fact that this presentation is structured
around the idea of communication and critical thinking.
Bill and tad must explain what various historical figures might bank and say
about their present day. World love San Demas,
which brings us to the other primary tension, myth versus history.
Whereas the history they learn in school is fixed and rigid,
made up of dates and hard to memorize facts, bill.
And Ted's a historical mission to bring figures of the past into the present is
the very stuff of myth-making by collecting Joan of arc,
Napoleon and crew, bill and tan are tearing apart.
The history that our literary society is so obsessed with sure.
They absorb actual facts along their interactive history lessons.
Nah, just got a minor Oedipal complex.
But they also use this new knowledge to draw a historical comparisons.
Time.
When much of the world looked like the cover of the lead chaplain album houses
of the whole.
They even called Socrates, the Ozzy Osborne of Athens underscoring.
What luck was caused the collapse of historical context,
taking place in favor of a more mythical style,
less concerned with literal truth.
What's more as Lonquist explains bill and Ted's myth telling unlike
rigid history can be customized to fit their audience of San demons,
high schoolers, nowhere more fittingly than in this moment.
X to each other.
Hardy on.
The evidence of bill and Ted is champions of an oral society is telegraphed.
When we see the future,
a place that has been changed by the power of bill and Ted's music,
where the words they have said in the past have been carried down across
generations.
Now I'm not entirely convinced, but my uncle was more,
she argues that the film sequel bill and Ted's bogus journey, further champions,
all society,
bill and Ted have apparently established a university where students learn
orally via headphones and through interactive lessons with historical
thickest, once more, the movies,
Dylan who wants to change history and dethrone bill and Ted as the world
saviors, I wise his diabolical plan in a book,
a book that he makes people read and calls the new history. Once again,
literary society is clearly the enemy of our favorite metal head duo.
Nan pays me a little bit to imagine a society where literature doesn't matter,
but I got to give it the lung lung is man.
The all versus written society bed is a little convincing.
I'm not saying that bill and Ted is intentionally saying all this. However,
we do think that the series maybe inadvertently makes a most
excellent argument about the power of active,
empowered learning in primarily all societies at the same time,
it majorly tampons,
the power of myths and helping us better understand the world and our place in
it. Why there, where the salaries of humanity are not.
And so in our final moments is bill and Ted deep are,
is it as dumb as an infinite loop of Keanu Reeves saying.
[Inaudible].
Raise your 10th grade American history teacher and write this take on this film
surprisingly incredibly deep,
but what do you guys think as wild stallions rotted?
Our brains are as there really a lot more going on in this film,
the first meets the eye, let us know in the comments as always huge,
thanks to our patrons for all your support, slam that subscribe button.
Like it's a portal to the future. And as always, thanks for watching.
[Inaudible].